foreign
this Jagged sheet of rock is hanging 200
feet above a walking trail next to the
Niagara River
it's already loose and if it falls it
could mean Serious injury to hikers on
the path below
that's where the Rope access team comes
in if they do their job just right most
of Niagara Falls 9 million yearly
visitors will never even know they were
here
thank you
first jump of the day
am I scared am I scared I have a healthy
respect that's all
this Cliff is located at Devil's Hole
State Park roughly four miles north of
Niagara Falls
team members like Andy and Christian
will scale the cliff and maintain the
crew's gear later Jake will clear
dislodged rocks from the trail those
rocks were to fall naturally there's
nothing stopping them from coming and
just plowing through somebody that's on
the trail so very necessary work what we
do here and you can see here all the
rocks that come down there pretty
sizable could cause some damage can you
hear me it's a dangerous job dehydration
injury and inclement weather are just
some of the risks thunderstorms are
forecast today so the team is on high
alert for signs of lightning which would
endanger the crew
we won't work in lightning that's about
it
we're gonna have fun you know usually
when we show this to people they say
they didn't even know this existed there
are 12 members of today's crew four
supervisors including Andy and eight
technicians
today their goal is to clear this entire
section of the cliff
their day begins at 7 A.M at the
maintenance shop where the team packs a
variety of gear into vehicles to take it
to the access point above the trail
see the fun thing about this is that I
don't actually jump with them every day
so today will be one of the days I jump
with them which is good because I've
been wanting to do this for a while
these are the guys who who do it every
single day and they're really really
good at it
after a short 10 minute drive the team
arrives at the access point and begins
gearing up
I guess we can start with the Peace Day
resistance
this is our climbing harness it's a
class three harness and it's called that
because of the shoulder straps the
shoulder straps prevent climbers from
slipping out of the harness if they
accidentally turn upside down and the
seat balances their body weight so that
blood flow to their legs isn't
restricted Comfort is also of the utmost
importance as climbers can be suspended
for more than two hours at a time
this device here is our bar rack this is
what we use to repel it's a pretty old
school device
we have a lot of mud and grit and when
the ropes get wet they swell so there's
not a lot of moving Parts it's all
friction so that's our descent device
all right
pretty much all ready to go here no one
cares about me everyone says Angie just
take care of yourself
so what they're talking about is some
some guys have a uh a rope Handler
watching their line and then some of us
are on what we call an ASAP which is
this this is your backup device and so
I'm just pulling control of all of my my
descent so I can actually step over the
edge now
am I scared am I scared I have a healthy
respect that's all
the crew's really close you know we joke
around a lot but when it is time to
actually go over the edge and do work
you know we kind of call that game time
because it is you know you need to take
it seriously because there's a lot of
risks involved
this program that we're part of has been
going on since about the 1930s and about
the whole time they've been using Pike
poles
there's a lot of utility with this this
is made out of solid fiberglass here so
if it gets into the the cliff this can
Flex a lot you can use this to position
yourself on the wall and then you can
use this to you know gently remove
debris you know you can grab stuff with
the hook gently pull it out it can fit
into cracks and then you can get
leverage that way
one of the things that makes removing
these rocks especially challenging is
that these Cliffs undergo something
called differential erosion which means
that areas of the cliff erode at
different rates layers of shale rock
located lower on the cliff side wear
away more quickly than the layer of
dolomite rock at the top that leaves
large unstable chunks of rock sometimes
the size of an SUV hanging at the
Cliff's Edge the crew uses a controlled
swing to gain access to material beneath
overhangs to do this they push
themselves away from the wall with their
feet to maintain that controlled
movement
hahaha
these are softball shin pads and they
work really really well for what we do
you try not to knee the wall but
sometimes for stability purposes you
know you you can't really help it we all
try to wear steel toe or some sort of
composite toe rocks are hard you know
you can't always Dodge a rock when
you're moving so you know having
something like that to keep yourself
safe is is a hundred percent necessary
[Music]
so all the rocks that are knocking down
are essentially coming right to the
trail and then some and they're going
right to the Niagara River which we have
right deer below us
[Music]
it's 10 a.m the crew is only about
two-thirds of the way through their
climb when the one thing they're worried
about happens a storm
the crew hears Thunder and spots
lightning as they are on the Cliffside
they need to stop working immediately
that will end their progress for today
so today we actually had to cut short we
have metal pipe poles in our hand we've
got a lot of metal gear on us so we just
try to get out of there as quickly as we
could anything that's going to pose a
hazard to the employees then we just
stop
the crew had only been working on the
200-foot Cliffside for less than an hour
when the storm began on a typical day it
could take the crew up to three hours to
clear a whole section when they're able
to resume they'll finish removing rocks
from the lower section of the cliff and
then stabilize the slope side with wire
meshing
this is the
Pier that we're gonna try to try clear
this all out so we can essentially have
an open hiking trail here again and it's
going to take a good bit of work and a
good bit of time to get this cleared out
to be safe for us to open it again
back at the shop the crew does paperwork
and washes their gear there's actually a
lot of paperwork required with all this
stuff and then also just keeping their
gear clean
you can kind of see from my shirt I'm
filthy from one junk today and you know
if this is how I look our gear is even
worse
so soapy water helps break it and like
lift the dirt using a toothbrush too to
get in there and then using an air
compressor to spray any of the soap in
and the dirt that's in there and then we
have a lubricant too when it's dry to
get in there and it's uh prevents rust
and corrosion
after the Rope access team has made some
progress it's time to start clearing the
rocks from the walking paths below this
is where the gorge crew comes in
we take care of about seven trails in
total within the gorge itself and then
two up top on top side now we are in the
process of cleaning the trail and
rebuilding it we've already come down
cleared the loose debris off the trail
and then started staging to get ready
for the bigger jobs
one of those jobs includes a specialized
stabilization technique to ensure the
slope side is secure
so down here to fix these Trails we use
game of baskets it's a six foot by three
foot Cube that is made of wire meshing
and what you do is you dig them down
place them within within Trail or
wherever you need them and then you add
Rock to the inside so that the rock
weighs it down drop like this can take a
week or two but if we have a good day
where we're really rocking and getting
stuff done it can be up maybe a three to
four day job now this Mount right here
we have all Android deck I'd like to see
you hopefully by the end of the summer
we get a majority of it taken out and
then we have put in some stabilization
techniques to help build the trail back
up so I could definitely see us working
into the fall and if I had to make a
guess it'll probably be open next summer
[Music]
I think if you're going to do this kind
of work at the core you have to enjoy
working Outdoors you get to see special
things that people don't see plants and
animals like the landscape the work that
you do it's really hard but then you're
helping keep the park safe you make a
meaningful difference if you're just a
parked user you might not even realize
we were ever there and that's kind of
the point
[Music]